I was telling you guys at one time my
freshman ya didn't take a shift for a
week and I had I I was addicted to stake
them as the merry good Jesus and all
right a Frenchman I play freshman ball
and we're playing Pattinson Eastside
it's just a jungle over school like you
got to be careful you going there and we
went there to play the Christmas
tournament but what kind of bar are we
talking right that's a basketball I
hadn't taken this [ __ ] for like ten days
I laptop something I took acid something
[ __ ] my stomach I didn't tell nobody
and while we will wait that my stomach
started hurting I said Jesus Christ I
love all my [ __ ] myself a fart well let
me just take a chance and I blew this
fart Joe Rogan that was so bad right we
want a boss and people started running
you know those school buses people
started running to the windows right to
swing down the bus windows but here's
where I fought it again
oh my god Boston I was [ __ ] god-awful
I wrote a blog about one of joeys farts
once is that my plane
yes yeah I think I read that